first of all thank you so much for
sitting down with me a big fan of both
of your work so I'm gonna start with a
direct question to you I would imagine
that there are the the the superhero
movie the superhero genre is the most
popular genre on the planet what was it
about venom that said this is the
character i want to play this is this is
the one just not superhero to me yeah
but you know what I mean like the comic
book genre I should say it like that
ok well ok pokel it just didn't strike
me here it's the least comic book for me
of the superhero ward if that makes
sense at the Marvel Board he's more
inclined for me grassman's the Jekyll
and Hyde dynamic between the interior
conflict and how venom kind of
symbolizes an inside voice or self will
run riot which has been given to an
alien from outer space or a higher
purpose in many a space and then
connected with the human being so I was
looking at it from a different angle and
this is really interested in my point we
have all the ippolit the assets that you
know a studio can can offer us with
visual effects you do stunts due to you
know design enemies aspects to imbue
ultimately an inner conflict between a
man and a woman will person with their
you know inside voice which is manifest
in a in a beast which they have to
negotiate an ethical framework with
within a world of good and bad which is
not binary but grey and I found that
very colorful and exciting I definitely
want to ask you the I have so much
enjoyed also your work the last few
years what has it been like for you
being like someone who's been trying to
make it you know what I mean get the pro
get a great role and all of a sudden
landing these great parts I especially
love sisters brothers you know after
name of recent movie Thank You Man um
you know I think the great parts exist
in every different scale of film you
know you can do really tiny indie movies
I know some of some films that we both
done there have been like you know much
smaller scale we really enjoyed that and
they feel like great parts you know so I
don't think it's so much about the scale
of film you're doing it's more about the
roles themselves in terms of how it's
felt going through this journey actually
it's what tom is actually someone who
known for a long time and every
different a few different stages of my
career someone who I've reached out to I
remember when I first was in shift e
which is the first film that was the
lead role of anywhere yeah and I
remember I phoned up Tom and I was like
dude how is this stuff work like I've
got premier need to get soup like what's
the deal you know and so I think it I
think on any kind of journey it helps if
you've got a kind of community of peers
and I think that sometimes something
that we don't have as much but but yeah
thankful for the people who've been
around me and unit national you know
this James National Theatre when you
wait that you think yes version SDF um
one of the scenes that I love is in the
movie is you going into the tank the
lobster tank oh right yeah it cooled off
it is fantastic because it just shows
also how like I love that you're always
willing to go for it in the in the
performance and that scene you're
playing someone completely unhinged
losing their mind jumping in the tank
what is it like because I heard that was
kind of improv of the day before like
you've thought about going in we had to
build a tank it was improved and then a
couple of weeks before because they felt
good a tank that would hold my weight
with lobsters in it as well and so it
was a big big sort of shifting sort of
would you be would it be cool if I did
this so yeah would be but it was a great
a lot of effort that's a make manifest
to just be it was something that I
thought was cool and not just that I
think was relevant as well to because
he's he's heating up he has a
temperature he needs to eat something
alive you know and initially was you ran
across the restaurant and pretty sounded
all smashed his fist through an aquarium
and grabbed the lobster out and bit it
and him passed out
it was so it was the same it was the
same yak in many aspect from the
material boiling point then I must get
in your swimming pool concept and he
gets into the lobster tank cools down
his temperature and then whilst talking
about other people being mad he he
attacks a live creature and he sustains
venom sustains his first I've very much
enjoyed that scene for to the two of you
is my last question I'm always curious
how actors like to
work on set some people love the Clint
Eastwood method of shooting a rehearsal
doing a take or two and they're done and
some people love like the David Fincher
method of filming like 50 takes or 99
takes how do you two typically like to
work and how has it changed throughout
your career I think it changes from job
to job and from project to project as
well I think for something like this
I've felt grateful that we had more
space and time to really tweak and
refine things there's often very
technical aspects you're in big sets
there's lots of cameras you've got hit
marks so with that kind of stuff you
need I feel like I need more takes to
get to a place where I can then forget
about the technical stuff where is
unlike kind of Indies films like
handheld and it's all like the
relationship drama I feel like it's kind
of helpful sometimes to go you get to
crux of this because it just lights a
fire so I think it changes for different
scale of projects and different vibe of
project you know yeah you're I think
it's alchemy and it depends on the
people you're working with and well the
team how the team is working I don't
need any specific way to work as long as
you know everyone's happy and
everybody's enjoying themselves and
getting the best out of themselves
that's great and what we see on the
clock so as quick as possible
that'd be nice as well cool I got to
stop there thank you both so much for
talking to me
you